[音楽]
グーン
こんにちは
ね早速自己紹介をしようかなと思うんですけど僕自己紹介がちょっと苦手でして難しく
ないですか
その時に肩書きって便利ですよね
きっと皆さんの明示にも社長とかどうでしょうまるまるリーダーとか
まるまる担当とかまるまる大臣とかいら先生方ですか
あとはデザイナーエンジニアライターみたいにこう
食しを書いている方も
かもしれないし
主婦とか学生みたいなもちろん立派な肩書だと思います
それが書いたね名称こう私は不問です渡す訳ですけど僕はいつもモヤモヤするんですね
これどれくらい自分伝わっているのかなーみたいだ
宜しくお願いします度かなーみたいな
肩書きってそもそも必要なのかな
何なのかなそんな肩書きのそもそものところから僕の話を始められたらなと思ってい
ます
ということで遅れましたがいい
勉強家の兼松よシロと申しますよろしくお願いします
[拍手]
もう帰りたくなった方いらっしゃいませんかなんか変な人ねぇ
いやーいますよでも安心してくださいとか変ですけど一応京都精華大学という大学で
大学教員をしています
あるいはその前はですねグリーンズ. jp というウェブマガジンの編集長をしてい
ました
ですねあとは2つの npo の理事もしています
変わったところで言うとこの秋からですね山梨県の美濃部町という町の観光大使を
務めることになりました
ちょっと安心しましたかね大学教員とか編集長とか
リッジと観光大使
って言われるとあーなんかそれなりにやってる人なのかなみたいなことですかね
今入ったのって役職とか何をしているかということだと思うんですけど僕はそれを
do の肩書と呼んでいますするの2ですね
じゃあ
勉強勝手な8連というと僕は勉強することが大好きな人なんですって言う
こんな人ですってのを表すための肩書きなんです
それを僕は be動詞の b b の肩書と呼んでいます
それを図にするとこの中でその do と b がなんか立って期待しているとかそう
いうことだけしてなくて今世の中であるものとか
まあ外から見えるもの島になっているものが do の方がきたとすればそれを島
たらしめているマグマがその者にあるはずなんですよ
噴火してポコってねそれが島になっているその
マグマの部分を p の肩書と呼びたいなと思っているんです
それが僕にとっては勉強かなんですね
僕がその勉強家っていうのは名乗り始めた乗せもう10周年
今40歳なんですけどもちょうど30才の時でした
少し僕の肩書の歴史なんですけど20代はですねその肩書きをすごく悩んだ
10年だったんですね
一番最初にもらった方が家は web デザイナー
でした
かっこよくないですか web でちゃうこの中にいらっしゃるかもしれませんで僕
あのぶっちゃけ秋田生まれの田舎者でしてあの地元に帰ったらシェア方やされるような
そんな仕事がしたかったんですね
デザイナー最高と思って憧れてたんですっで沿岸かなって
web デザイナーになりました夢が叶えました
けどそこから悩み始めるんですね
デザイナー web デザイナーであることが当たり前になって2年目
本当にこれやりたかったのかな
そんなクエスチョンが浮かんできたんです
でちょっと思うところがあって転職した時に14歳で転職した時は art って楽茶
ちょっと修正しますよねけど社員4人しかいないで
デザイナー一人セルフディレクションです
ねえ1もん勝ちみたいなでそのさらに五年後フリーランスとして独立しますしその時の
パティ sause アクアしか愛しますさらに言語
グリーンズっていうそのさっきのメンバーがいいましたがそこに正式に関わるときには
クリエイティブ聚楽とスラッシュデザイン上なりつつ
ねっかっこいいさらにその2年後30歳の時にはですね
ここまできましたコンテンツでれたら雑誌グリーンジャーナリスト
まあ
ね節操なくとっかえひっかえそれっぽいを小文字の肩書を並べてきました
あれ和子長いで削っていいですか見たらそんなこともありました
ってなんでこんなふうにねいっぱい支えてきたかというと
自分的にはですね発破を掛けたかったんです
俺はこれになるんがだからこれを名乗ってもっともっと成長するんだそれをご上の
ところで特価日かやってきたわけですけれども
ある時この一部が入っていることと自分ができていることに何かごギャップを感じる
ように
だったんですね正直半年か全く仕事ができない
鬱っぽくなってしまって仕事を休んだ時期もありました
そのときはこんな感じです
私は何者なんだろう
何がしたかったんだろう
これが30歳のときです
でっ
転機となったのが勉強家っていうキーワードだったんですね
それは友人から二と言われた一言だったです
僕用舟艇を張ったんですけど4種ってさーいいつも勉強してるよねー
勉強大好き勉強からねって言われたんです人から言われる言葉ですよね選挙で最初僕は
あっっバカにされてるって思ったわけすっごれ取っちゃうっ
でも本気で言ってくれてるし僕自身なんかこう
これ一番今まででシック
いいくる自分の呼び方肩書きかも
ピンときたんですすごく勝つとハマった気がしますね
うわこれがあったらも上なんでもいいんじゃないかたってそれぐらい
思いました
勉強家っていうのですね友人からのプレゼントだったわけです
けれどもそれが僕にとってかなり大きな意味を持ち始めて人生を変えます
勉強家にいろんな意味を込めているんですけども一つ目は本当に好奇心のも温まり
どんなものを選んだりしていいんですね空海の本を読んだりソーシャル時代の本読ん
だりいろいろやってるとですねこれこれとこれがここでつながれじゃんみたいな
一つ g を光が見えてきたりするその時にはザーって全身が鳥肌が立つ
それが勉強会とっての醍醐味のひとつです
あるいは僕は勉強かなので専門家には勝てません
けど一生懸命チャレンジします実験もして失敗もたくさんしてできるようになろうと
する
えいえんのアマチュアなんですね
というのも編集長と言いましたが品種未経験で編集しをやりました
大学教員って言ってますが僕修士号を持っていません
すべて一から試行錯誤してなんとか形にしていく
でも専門家じゃないからこそアマチュアだからこそ
打ち出せる新鮮な価値っていうのもやっぱりあるんですよね
でそれまではダンて中途半端な自分なんだろう
で自分をコンプレックスをだったと思うせめてないんですけども
そうではなくてこれはいろんなことにチャレンジしたい
そういうあり方なんだという風に勉強家と名付けたことで自己肯定できるようになった
んです
僕は今もうすぐ40歳で京都精華大学との契約もあと2年で終わるんですね
さてこの後どうしようっていうことなんですけどももしかしたら起業するかもしれない
し
就職活動をちゃんとするだろうしあるいは誰かから来一緒にやらないって声をかけて
いただけるかもしれません
もしかしたらスナックを経営してるかもしれないし高野山で
でお坊さんが来るかもしれない
でも
そこで一番大事にしたいのはこの真ん中と真ん中の勉強家である自分が喜びを感じ
られるかどうか
その遠いをずっと持ち続けていたいなと思っていますまあ bbb
言ってねけどこれ決して do の肩書を否定しているわけではないです
むしろ b の敵と同じくらい e ドゥーエの肩書も大事ですね
この do という島の部分でどうマグマを発揮するのか
1人
素敵な方をご紹介したいと思います
そんな方はですね
京都市のバスのうて悲惨なんですけども
本当に車内アナウンスが面白いんですよ
色々ネタがあってですねちょっと僕がまねせるとあまりつまんなくなるのでちょっと
あの辛抱していただきたいですけど一つだけ
あのご披露すると
皆さん最近は忘れ物が多くなっておりますのでご注意ください
最近多いはするものは携帯電話
傘財布あまりそうですよねイヤホン
てんのかちょっと細いな
ガラケーちょっと細かくすぎないかな iphone イレブン
iphone イレブン pro iphone イレブン promax やいや
それそこまでみたいなあーっあーっ
あとですねパーたーーー処方箋のスクールあ所詮チャーミンってカッコ情景が浮かび
ますよね
その30個くらい高列挙したりしてすごいもうじゃないかとか
か笑つつまれるわけですけど
ブーバーからですけど aki とっての最高の晴れ舞台っていうのは劇場でもテレビ
でもなくてば
頭の中
なんです
同じようにこの中でもしかしたら小説家になりたいと思ってる方がいるかもしれません
がその方がもし保育士さんをしているとすればね毎週絵本を作って子供たち読み聞かせ
する
そんなのもステキかもしれません
けどそれが100冊ぐらいだったら本当に出版社さんから出版しませんかあってくるか
もしれないですよね
コメディアンのようなパスの運転士さん
小説家のような保育士さ
この do の肩書と b の肩書をかけザこの交わるところがその人の個性であり
その人にしかできない働き方なんじゃないかなあと僕は思っています
なのであの b の肩書を見つけた
じゃあ今の仕事辞めればとかそういうことでは決してなくて
こういう b の肩書きがあるから今これをやれているんだなぁこれでよかったな
みたいに今の仕事を愛せるようになる
そんなのも僕の願いです
でねじゃあ b の方が来てどうやったら見つけたらいいのって思った方いるかもしれ
ませんが最後に3つの問いをみなさんにプレゼントできたらなと思います
一つ目は
自分にとっては
まあごくごく当たり前のことなんだけどもなんだか周りからやたらすごいねって言わ
れることありませんか
僕だったらこうやって人前で話す額なのはみんなできるんじゃないのって思うわけです
けどそうではないらしい
例えばイラスト錠剤と言うじゃないですか皆のみんなイラスト上だと思っていますよね
僕はそんなことないって
つまり得意技って自分では意外とわかってなくて当たり前にできることを他の人に教え
ても
なんかそれって凄いんだよと教えてもらうことってすごく大事なんじゃないかなと思っ
ています
それが一つね二つ目はこんな瞬間が続いてほしいなあってしみじみ思う事ってどういう
ことですか
で僕の b の肩書きは勉強家もありますがあとコメディアンてのたぶんそういう成分
もありそうますよね
そのコメディアン成分の僕にとってはちょっとこう笑って頂けたりするとああやって
良かったなーって思うわけです笑ってもらうことで自分は花開く
だからぁが大学の授業っていうのも自分にとってすごく楽しい時間なのかなぁと思っ
たり
してい
あと3つ目はですね人から何かを頼まれたときにあそれならお役に立てそうだな
自分の力を十分に発揮できそうだなそう思うような事ってどういうことでしょうか
僕で言うと
あの左右の目のですねし力の差が激しすぎて立体感覚でない人間なんせん
ソースも完全に打ち間違えます自分の親指を言ってしまいます
だからもう diy は僕には戦力なら何かこうかけてくださいって言っちゃうんです
けどじゃあ結婚式の司会やっていた方も喜んでやるよみたいなね
まぁそんな感じです
ん
イマミったみたいな3つの通りですね
自分にとっては当たり前なんですけどもなんかもありからやたらすごいねと言われる事
ってなんですか
こんな時間がずっと続けばいいなぁとしみじみ思うことはなんでしょうか
人から頼まれたときにこんなことならすぐできるよ
力を発揮できそうと思うことはなんでしょうか
そんな深い自分と向き合えるという
持っていただきながらぜひ皆さんも b の方が気の探求していただけたらなと思い
ます
勉強家の兼松でしたありがとうございました
[拍手]